i am nick gillespie with my reason
colleague and Declaration of
Independence co-author Matt Welch and we
are at ask a libertarian day via
Facebook reader Matthew teegarden
Esquire politicians always hell-bent on
subsidizing stadiums for sports teams
Matthew comes from Minnesota and he's
talking about the Vikings stadium which
is a big new tax thing going on there
God knows there's no reason to be
subsidizing the Vikings they owe every
taxpayer in Minnesota hell of a lot of
money and I don't know how you Brett you
know you mend a broken heart but let's
let's get at it Vikings there is no
reason why anybody should be subsidizing
sports its corporate welfare and it's
worse but that doesn't get to the
political question in the political
equation here which is that politicians
have an edifice complex and they love
giving money to sports stars and two
celebrities and billionaires the anytime
I hear anyone talk about welfare queens
in one breath and then talk about
building a new cowboy stadium on the
taxpayer a dull in the next they deserve
all the hell that's going to come
raining down on their head yeah and this
is there there have been successful
places where we're whole cities whole
States whole region say hey no way we're
not putting up with this and economic
research shows that having a major
sports team in your city does not
actually help the local economy in fact
some economists offended it reduces
local GDP so there's no reason
economically and now it's time to hold
the politicians feet to the fire and say
no we do not want this and we're not
taking our tax dollars and making
millionaires and billionaires even
richer
you